premier budget d'eric girard premier
budget de la coalition avenir québec pas
de baisses d'impôts pas de baisses de
taxes de la tvq non plus malgré les
milliards de dollars en plus des
milliards depuis quelques années au
québec et particulièrement au cours de
derniers exercices ya des allègements
fiscaux qui s'ajoute à l'ocassion
famille qui avait été annoncé dans
l'énoncé économique qui s'ajoute au
soutien des années notamment un crédit
pour le prolongement de sa vie au
travail après 60 ans le crédit rouler
vert pour acheter une voiture électrique
notamment qui prolongeait jusqu'en 2021
une exemption également d'impôts sur les
revenus qui proviennent des pensions
alimentaires ou de différents programmes
qui entoure la pension alimentaire
mais on mise sur tout je vous dirais sur
des éléments fondamentaux pour faire
croître l'économie à long terme donc les
soins à domicile c'est très nécessaire
le personnel soignant supplémentaire des
classes et des services spécialisés pour
les enfants pour les jeunes dans les
écoles et un soutien à la main d'oeuvre
joly dit cette bonification pour les
travailleurs expérimentés la
francisation des immigrants beaucoup
d'argent pour aider pour accompagner les
migrants dans le marché et de l'argent
dans les infrastructures 15 milliards de
plus sur 10 ans au maintien des marges
de manoeuvre extrêmement important
surplus l'an passé surplus avant le
versement des fonds ils font des
générations le fonds des générations
poursuit on à 10 milliards dans la
réserve de stabilisation une marge de
manoeuvre sont très très importante ce
qui fait qu'on peut se demander si le
gouvernement le nouveau gouvernement
n'aurait pas pu accélérer certaines
mesures comme les maisons des années
l'abolition ou l'uniformisation de la
taxe scolaire le soutien aux aînés et le
tarif unique en garderie c'est seulement
180 millions le gouvernement a choisi de
faire ça sur quatre ans le défi
économique demeure le bassin de la
population en âge de travailler va
baisser
l'économie va baisser donc le
gouvernement joue de prudence